[Aplausos]
ele não consegue ver muito mais equipe se
é tarde demais
junto com minha vida profissional começou a
1980 como um oficial de infantaria
do exército argentino continuou a
anos 90 como engenheiro militar em
informática cuidando da informática do
hospital militar e colégio militar
os anos 2000 já aqui e não o brasil
como engenheiro de computação e como
especialista em gestão a quem me dediquei
consultoria e redes de computadores e
nesta década eu temo que eu não tenha virado
um pouco mais para a ciência da
computação com alguma produção
científica uma área de computação em nuvem e
de seguro de informação e ao longo
de todo aquele dia, apesar do grande
mudanças e desafios era sempre o mesmo
aproveitar ao máximo
tecnologias existentes em todos os momentos
por vir aconteceu naqueles
empreendedorismo e curiosamente
um problema com o qual temos que lidar
principal obstáculo sempre foi também
as mesmas pessoas parecem ter um
grande curiosidade das tecnologias que
vivem mais raramente sabem e são
dispostos a usar aqueles que já
estão disponíveis e isso é
particularmente verdadeiro nos dias de
hoje poucas pessoas em plena consciência
do poder que a tecnologia coloca hoje
literalmente nas nosas mouse e como
tinha afetado bundas ácidas
quando se trata de estudar para o curso superior
como aproveitar a tecnologia e
como as tecnologias versus a sociedade
águas turbulentas e sempre use um
modelo simples muito conhecido
útil que é um modelo da terceira onda de
alvin toffler alvin toffler diz isso
a humanidade avançou em três grandes ondas e
em cada um de um ser humano
adquiriu novas capacidades que mudaram
sociedade plena a primeira onda
foi a revolução agrícola quando um ser
humano aprende a dominar a natureza
cultivar a terra para domesticar
animais na cidade nenhuma tese de mestrado
nômade vai correr atrás de comida ou desejo
sente-se e a sociedade nasce de como nós
sei que hoje é a segunda onda foi a
revolução industrial com a invenção do
a máquina um ser humano multiplica sua
capacidade de realizar trabalho físico
multiplica sua capacidade de colocar
energia em um trabalho e assim adquirir a
capacidade de produzir em larga escala
de zelo como ver em alta velocidade e
incluindo a destruição em larga escala
assim a tranquilidade da segunda onda
deu lugar à velocidade do ruído ao clandestino
sociedade industrial a terceira grande
onda foi para a revolução do computador
com a invenção da reclamação de computador
máquina que permite automatizar um
cálculo e processamento
informação um ser humano multiplica sua
capacidade de pensar em gerar
conhecimento e com isso dá origem a um
nova etapa da sociedade e coincidem
como uma sociedade de seu conhecimento neste
a sociedade não é mais tão importante
quantidade de como foi a revolução
indústria e torna-se relevante para
atualidade de precisão e um fator de
poder torna-se realmente o
informações a tomada correta de
decisões
alvin toffler
Eu estudo as características da sociedade
Em cada uma dessas etapas e
principalmente esses dois critérios de
eventos dois empreendimentos como este levando
exemplo de guerra que foi um dos
Assuntos que o professor trapaceia
para a guerra a primeira onda seria derrotada
para aquele exército que tvc mais animais
um coletivo acabaria mais forte
uma revolução industrial na segunda
onda a guerra seria vencida por isso
estivese mais máquinas maior capacidade
destruição primeiras metralhadoras
então blindado então aviões um
derrota na guerra da terceira onda quem é
superior em uma área de conhecimento e
passa a ser um objetivo prioritário da
exércitos destroem sistemas
informações inimigas que não são mais
necessário
que tudo isso a distribuição que
característica que caracterizou o
guerras a segunda onda
Eu sempre fui apaixonado, mas um
modelo que foi publicado em 1980 quando
Comecei minha vida profissional
sempre acontece sempre para os alunos
mais quando chegarmos a 2010
Comecei a sentir que um modelo não era
o suficiente
que não explicou algumas coisas que
estavam acontecendo
ele tem uma percepção de que estávamos
entrando em uma quarta banda e várias vezes
sua diversidade ou benito frétigné
manifestou sobre isso mais ele ela
ele estava feliz que acabou morrendo aos 81 e
tudo novo 2016
não havia mais escola para mim do que
continuar um modelo para poder seguir
sofrendo com isso e para isso é definir e
desta forma definir o que somos
não há quarta idade onde o retorno de
humanidade e caminhamos em grande ritmo
acelerado para a quinta onda para
estender um modelo a base a
uma visão da evolução da internet
internet Eu fui criado na década de 1990
70 e por Peter 20 anos ela era uma
plataforma restrita ao uso científico e
militares mais do que o início da década do
90 foi aberto para uso comercial e
transformado em plataforma de negócios
e tem um primeiro estágio de evolução
que era conhecido como internet 2 com
tributos e sites mal eram estáticos
foram usados ​​para divulgar o conteúdo
poucos usuários que na época temos
acesso à internet mal tínhamos o
capacidade de leitura
o ano de 2000 algumas novidades
tecnologias que permitiram criar
aplicativos online
e uma nova etapa de evolução começa
da internet conhecido como internet dois
serviços onde seus usuários têm a
capacidade de integração com aplicativos
online como home banking como comércio
eletrônico
naqueles estágios duvidosos de evolução da
internet para internet continuou a ser
uma plataforma de negócios e houve
espectadores e protagonistas
usuários éramos simples espectadores mais
os anos 2000 foram extremamente
importante não desenvolvimento de
internet e computação como um todo
crescimento explosivo da internet tv
informática deve ser
totalmente reinventado para suportar
dimensão que levou a internet a um novo
múltiplos devem ser aumentados para
sistema métrico decimal para poder medir
as quantidades de informação
estavam traficando e sendo armazenados
a reportagem na internet
tecnologias que eram de laboratório
inteligência artificial tornou-se
amplamente utilizado a internet e assim
chegamos a 2010 inaugurando um novo
fase evolutiva da internet conhecida
como a internet que você dá às pessoas que têm três
Eles têm quatro características
importante que você gostaria de discutir com
seu próprio
a primeira daquelas
características é que a internet virou
A plataforma de convergência é um
que tem uma técnica um pouco mais fácil do que
Compreendo
anteriormente temos várias redes de
comunicações ei, existem todos
quem se comunica em um mundo acontece
pela internet e tecnicamente fez
tem consequências muito importantes
celular como tecnologia de inclusão
apesar de ser extremamente
importante e pouco tito contra
inclusão são os esforços para
aumentar os benefícios da computação para
todas as pessoas para democratizar
computando números de pedidos e tenta não
meras iniciativas de inclusão digital
liderada por governos
instituições por empresas de ensino
tipo newman impacto significativo de
de repente sem ser procurado sem esforço e
nenhum espontaneamente celular
se consolidou se impôs como uma tecnologia
de inclusão e o celular noten ouve todas as
mundo em que você depende de asúa
condição social a cidade do tipo de
trabalho que o fax de todos
praticamente todas as pessoas
celular que é fascinante porque hey não
somos todos praticamente todos
pessoas com um computador uma mão e não
um computador de onde qualquer celular é
hoje de muito mais poder de computação
supercomputadores dos anos 90 o que
é mais fácil de entender do que isso super
computador que tem isso em mãos
É usado principalmente para césar
poder de computação muito maior
infinitamente maiores do que são para a internet
computação em nuvem é um conceito
quando silenciamos alguns conteúdos em
essas fotos no facebook
onde esses conteúdos são armazenados
onde são processados ​​e isso não acontece
em alguns celulares que acontece na nuvem
alguns dizem que um servidor do facebook
como se um computador pudesse dar conta
dessa taxa para poder dar
suporte para redes sociais 'facebook' manter
dezenas de data centers exp aliados por
hair world todos os datacenters são
verdadeiras forças digitais onde
abrigar milhares de computadores que
chamamos servidores 20.000 30.000 40.000
servidores podem ter um data center
centenas normais de especialistas
trabalhando milhões de dólares em
software algum datacenter de
atualmente consome eletricidade e
água como cidades de 50 a 60 mil
habitantes e um mais fascinante do que há
as pessoas têm acesso a todo esse poder de
forma livre
quando eles pulam eu uso o celular
usando todos esses recursos
aumentos computacionais na forma
gratuito e isso nos leva à ideia de um
ser humano com capacidades estendidas
gosto de tamargueira ou de um ser humano com
Superpoderes
vejo algumas capacidades lúcidas dan
dúvida de cada venda não consegui nem
imaginar e considerou que aqueles
capacidades são verdadeiras superpotências
uma primeira superpotência que não
somos é um conhecimento infinito
informação infinita la palma dama o
qualquer coisa pergunte agora
para vozes vozes sabem o que era um
primeiro presidente de qualquer país que foi
terceiro votei em qual copo como o
letra de uma musica todo mundo sabe disso
não é normal é uma superpotência real
escritor argentino Jorge Luis Borges
fix 6 nasceu sonhei com espelhos
labirintos e uma biblioteca infinita
biblioteca que você vê todos os livros do
mundo
ou se não formos a palma da mão para
biblioteca infinita de borges e gordura
uma próxima superpotência que não somos
que a verdade é um par de todos
você superpodera essa colaboração
a capacidade de colaborar infinitamente
colaborar kerby ser trabalhar em conjunto um
primeira onda a trabalhar em conjunto e que
era necessário que nós somos o povo de
bem-estar em um lugar em um
momento com a internet como pessoas
temos capacidade infinita
colabore com todos e com todos
mundo sabe que a colaboração é
importantes vários oradores aqui
mencionar antes de terem mais de 20 anos e
fácil ter uma compreensão real
das consequências práticas
colaboração um exemplo que foi apreciado
muito para ilustrar isso e
atv sob demanda tb sob demanda a década
dos 90 alguns futurólogos da
colocar jazz eles disseram que não há futuro
temos tv sob demanda ou quem quer que seja
todo mundo vai assistir a um kicker como este
bayter muitos canais cada canal vai para
tem muitos programas
todos vão pensar ou querer
assistir e atender feito e impossível hoje
não somos ou youtube ou o que é um youtube
tb por demanda ou foi pensado que ele quer
ajudar a procurar e ajudar o que forte
fiz porque é possível que seja
amarelo como foi a empresa que colocou
todos felizes lá companhia ou junot em
esse poder ou juntando todas as empresas
mais poderoso hoje tinha isso
capacidade e sem graça é possível, mas o trabalho
colaboração de milhões de pesos
e assim podemos citar uma série de
outras superpotências se todas as consequências
dessa rede que temos e o
possibilidade infinita de colaborar
exemplo tão fácil ou se você está aqui não
Terá sido argentino ou nos EUA não sei
sabe exatamente como chegar a algum lugar
colocar quanto tempo vai demorar como é o
trânsito uma simples falta de era fazer um
edição e transmissão de vídeo
torná-lo disponível, mas muito para um mundo
isso é uma superpotência que é uma superpotência para
os anos 90 seria necessário
várias pessoas vários equipamentos
pesado e muito dinheiro e tempo para
facer e ouvir qualquer adolescente
fãs em um instante para aqueles porque é
superpoderes que tenho é que temos o
pessoas hoje e eu te digo que
internet das coisas caracteriza quarta
onda de retorno dá humanidade à internet
de eu ser uma plataforma de negócios
desejo de ser protagonistas e
espectadores somos todos protagonistas
internet é uma plataforma de qualidade
de vida para todas as pessoas
mudar totalmente a forma como
interagimos com outras pessoas
trabalhamos como estudamos como estudamos
nos divertimos e um fator de potência parou
ser a informação que hoje todos
Eu tenho e me tornei criatividade e
inovação
então nós somos
em um momento fascinante de evolução da
humanidade para a quarta onda e entender em
onde estamos podemos tentar entender
para onde vamos estamos vivendo
uma quarta fase da evolução da internet
e a tecnologia encerada conhecida como
internet das cousas a pior maneira de ver
para a internet das coisas é via
aquele gráfico humano 2000 digamos 500
computadores a internet não 2010 mais
passamos os 12 milhões a mais para ela
Eu tinha telefones celulares tablet
tevez nada no 2020 temos 50 milhões e
eles não serão mais apenas dispositivos
parte computacional convencional de
muitos objetos comuns ligados a
do que conectar objetos para automatizar um
uso diário para que um mundo para que
os objetos
para sanz governar um mundo de acordo com aqueles
necessidades com objetos devem ser
dotado de inteligência para atuar como
sensores e atuadores sensores são os
dispositivos que recebem informações
os atuadores do sistema são dispositivos
que modificam um mundo um mundo físico
por exemplo, as contribuições podem ser
inteligente saber quantas pessoas
temos aqui e eu poderia falar com um
sistema de ar condicionado por exemplo
para determinar quantos dispositivos
eles deveriam estar ligados que eu me mudaria em um
mundo físico sofreria mutação à temperatura
umidade
para as coisas da internet transformando você
tensionar rapidamente algumas áreas que
começar a ficar esperto nós temos um ao outro
hospitais de fábricas inteligentes
edifícios inteligentes inteligentes
temos fazendas inteligentes a ideia
O fim é integrar todos esses sistemas e
temos um mundo totalmente inteligente
que em um conceito irá caracterizar
quinta onda de evolução dá à humanidade
porque alguns ou superpoderes não serão mais
a esfera intelectual em conjunto será
digital será sobre um mundo físico
temos a capacidade de mudar um mundo
pessoas físicas ainda somos a quarta onda
no caminho para a quinta pergunta ou o que
vamos encarar para participar de eventos de
esse processo
bong para mim uma proposta é usar um
modelo para as Ilhas Baleares não são
empreendimentos são nossos projetos
questionar se estamos
propondo soluções próprias
quarta e quinta onda ou se estamos
fazendo pensando como ondas
anterior
a tecnologia está disponível estamos
obriga obrigado a usá-lo para
fazer metade das coisas que sempre
vamos corrigir e atualização da tecnologia psoe
mais em um mundo de transformações de
movendo tão grande e rápido alenda
atualização de tecnologia
as pessoas têm que questionar será
que devo mudar completamente para formar isso
coisas falsas ou teremos que fazer
coisas totalmente diferentes e que
transformação visitada parada zero
que devemos fazer outra coisa porque
aqui o que fazíamos ou não era fax
on off para mais significado e para terminar
mais uma das frases favoritas do alvin
toffler e disse a ele ou analfabeto fazer
seculo 21 não será aquele que não sabe ler
escrever e atenta pensar imediatamente
quem será aquele que não sabe lidar
tecnologia plus termina dizendo
analfabeto será aquele que não sabe
aprender a desaprender
aprender em um mundo onde a condição
da criatividade da condição do evento
e inovação é pont lembrar que como
vezes muito mais difícil de remover ou
encontre e você não será rápido
você toma velez multiplicado
[Aplausos]